merci jean-rmond Gounet de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de lessonne
apparenté au groupe les républicains
rapporteur spécial du budget de
l'audiovisuel dont on va parler dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité on l'a vu dans le journal
c'est cette grande interview donnée par
ellisabeth borne ce matin au Figaro
notamment sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme et après l'attaque au couteau
de samedi soir à Paris elle se dit prête
à aller plus loin pour protéger les
Français notamment dans la surveillance
des individus dangereux est-ce que cette
ligne de fermeté vous rassure
écoutez pas du tout pas du tout au
contraire l'heure n'est plus aux pris de
position devant les médias voyez ce que
je veux dire à l'indignation à la
fermeté c'est une fermeté de papier ce
qu'attendent les Français ce que nous
attendons maintenant ce sont des actes
concrets les Français ont peur de ce qui
se passe il ne se passe pas une semaine
maintenant sans qu'il y ait un drame
donc à l'évidence la situation est grave
et les Français attendent des mesures
qui soient de véritable mesure concrète
on va nous parler on va encore faire de
la législation poudre aux yeux qui ne va
pas servir à grand-chose aujourd'hui il
faut encore une fois restaurer cette
autorité cette fermeté dont nous avons
besoin pour la sécurité des Français et
le gouvernement n'est pas la hauteur
pour
vous je je je n'aime pas critiquer comme
ça gratuitement parce que croyez-moi
être à la place d'un Premier ministre
aujourd'hui ça doit pas être évident
mais quand même quand même les simples
interpellations lors des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement les réponses
qui nous sont faites
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il y a
une certaine à la fois une rigidité de
façade mais ce qu'on voudrait c'est
qu'on nous écoute surtous les bancs il
se dit des choses très intéressantes au
Sénat et malheureusement le gouvernement
n'en tient pas compte alors justement
Bruno rotayo le patron des sénateurs les
républicains veut déposer une nouvelle
proposition de loi pour étendre la
rétention de sûrté aux condamnation pour
terrorisme le débat a été rouvert
évidemment après cette attaque
ellisabeth borne elle se dit pas fermé
euh à la proposition elle ouvre la porte
sans pour autant l'ouvrir vraiment mais
vous vous rendez compte à quel point
nous en sommes arrivés c'està-dire des
propositions de bon sens les Français
n'y comprennent plus rien ils apprennent
tous les jours que des
fous sont dehors que des fichiers sont
dehors comment sont-ils surveillés
comment sont-ils surveillés quand ils
cumulent les deux malheureusement
défauts comment sont-ils surveillés on
apprend que des gens comme ça peuvent se
retrouver dehors que vous pouvez les
croiser dans sur le trottoir dans la rue
les Français ne le comprennent plus
alors qu'elle ne ferme pas la porte
c'est à minima c'est pas cette porte- là
qu'il faudrait fermer voyez ce que je
veux dire ouais mais juste juste as dit
qu'il y a déjà des textes sur la table
et que ces textes sont des outils
puissants depuis très longtemps il
existe dans ce pays des textes parce que
nous ne sommes pas les législateurs
arrivés depuis hier vous voyez ce que je
veux dire donc on a déjà des base on a
tout ce qu'il faut faut-il ensuite que
la
justice faut-il encore que la justice
puisse voilà être dans l'esprit non
seulement le le texte de ces lois mais
également l'esprit de ces lois voilà la
porte que vous voulez fermer on imagine
que c'est celle de l'immigration le
projet de loi est en discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale il arrivera en
séance lundi ellisabeth borne est
confiante sur sa majorité et sur la
capacité de Gérald haranin à en trouver
une vous êtes optimiste vous sur l'issue
de ce texte qui a été détricoté par les
députés la version sénatoriale he alors
très clairement le texte qui sort du
Sénat nous avons fait le travail
nécessaire c'est-à-dire que il y avait
plusieurs postures aussi on pouvait dire
très bien ce texte ne nous va pas il
n'est pas nous avons travailler sur ce
texte et croyez-moi que François Noël
buffet Muriel Jourda pour parler de
justement de du groupe les républicains
et François Noël buffet président de de
la commission un travail très strict
très précis très profond a été fait ce
la caricature qui est présentée dans
dans les médias disons que c'est un
texte voilà non je vous le garantis euh
ce qui c'est un texte équilibré qui
répond aux demandes des Français encore
une fois il s'agit pas de renier notre
tradition en France mais il s'agit de
savoir qui boit qui paye aujourd'hui
dans ce pays donc ça veut dire que pour
ce texte soit voté il faut que ce soit
la version du Sénat qui soit reprise où
est-ce qu'un compromis est possible
alors là si c'était un compromis en
commission mixte paritaire ça serait
pire que tout parce que ça voudrait dire
que ça se négocie sous le manteau pour
ma part le texte du Sénat rien que le
texte du Sénat il a été tricooté à
l'Assemblée il ne ressemble plus du tout
à ce qu'il était quand il est sorti du
Sénat sur ce sujet de l'immigration il y
a un autre texte c'est la niche des
républicain aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
c'est-à-dire que ce sont leurs textes
qui est qui sont examinés aujourd'hui il
y a notamment un texte qui vise à
remettre en cause l'accord
franco-algérien c'est un accord qui
accorde un statut favorable aux
ressortissants algériens pour leurs
conditions de séjour d'emploi et les
républiicains veulent le remettre en
cause soutenu par horizon d'ailleurs sur
ce sujet vous vous soutenez ce texte
bien sûr pourquoi mais encore une fois
pas de la façon dont on le
présente ces dernières heures dans les
médias
c'est déjà il faut savoir et encore une
fois il faut rentrer dans les textes il
faut travailler les choses la commission
l'a fait au niveau de la commission des
lois dans la le projet de loi de finance
2024 François Noël buffet encore
muriette Jourda et Philippe boncarer
puisqu'ils sont les les rapporteurs mais
il y a 110 conventions dans laquelle la
France est partie voyez 110 conventions
donc on pe comprendre que dans ces
conventions là entre le moment où elles
ont été passées et aujourd'hui il s'est
passé un petit peu de choses ce que l'on
demande c'est de revoir là il s'agit du
2 si j'ai bonne mémoire 27 décembre 1968
cette convention avec l'Algérie donc
elle est à revoir à l'évidence parce que
des choses ont évolué et je pense que ça
va dans le bon sens et là Elisabeth B
dit que les discussions sont ouvertes
mais bien entendu et de façon sereine
mais en même temps Renaissance voté
contre ah bah vous savez déjà les votes
renaissan
il faut savoir un petit peu comment il
s'oriente moi je renaissante c'est voilà
c'est François Baayou qui parlait du
centre en disant que c'était une
brouette de
grenouille voilà Renaissance je ne sais
pas à quelle brouette il faudrait la
comparer mais bon peu importe mais je
crois que aucun parti d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui ne peut donner de leçons
là-dessus très modestement hein pas les
juste sur ce texte hier en conseil des
ministres selon les informations du
figuero Emmanuel Macron aurait taclé ce
texte des républicains je n'avais pas
compris que la politique étrangère de la
France était définie au Parlement aurait
dit le président de la République quen
dites-vous ah c'est une sortie qui lui
ressemble bien en ce moment les les
sorties médiatiques sont à la mode mais
euh voilà il a il a dire d'expert si je
peux bien bien évidemment la politique
étrangère et le domaine réservé du
président de la République par la
Constitution de 1958 mais cette même
constitution de 1958 vous savez pour un
élu local l'article 72 sur la libre
administration des communes elle est
quelque peu bafoué par la politique du
président Emmanuel Macron et notamment
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
on va reparler des collectivités
territoriales ce sera l'ctu dans votre
région mais d'abord un mot sur cette
phrase hier qui a été prononcée par le
président du Sénat Gérard Larché c'était
sur RTL il était interrogé sur les
positions de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sa ligne
et notamment son tweet qui attaquait la
journaliste routel CRIF et Gérard
Larcher lui a lancé ferme ta gueule
est-ce que vous auriez dit ça vous aussi
oui et je dois vous avouer que quand je
suis bien sûr les les interventions
médiatiques du président Larcher et je
lui ai envoyé un message d'amitié de
respectueux et d'amitié en le le
remerciant d'avoir dit tout haut ce que
une écrasante majorité de Français pense
et et envie de dire à Jean-Luc
mélenchant quand il se perd parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui a du talent quand il
se perd dans dans ses outrances voilà
alors une chose est très simple
euh aujourd'hui vous savez si on doit
parler normalement quand on est
politique il faut coconstruire de façon
pragmatique la bienveillance du vivre
ensemble voilà ce langage là les
Français n VE plus si vous écoutez
l'intervention de Gérard Larcher il y a
un développement très équilibré très
précis comme il le fait d'habitude et à
la fin comme une chute comme Michel
Audiard l'aurait mis dans la la bouche
de Jean Gabin ou de Bernard bliet il dit
ferme ta gueule
mais alors peut-être que le mot gueule
c'est celui-là qui dérange ferme-la
voyez on a envie de lui dire ça à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ferme-la c'est
quelqu'un de grand talent il est de mon
département d'origine he c'est un
Estonien on l'a connu c'est quelqu'un de
grand talent de grande culture qui se
perd de façon catastrophique pour des
raisons euh électoralistes tout le monde
l'a bien compris donc Gérard lcher a
exprimé là il l'a fait avec un naturel
une profondeur même un respect parce que
vous savez quand il dit les élus sont
àortés d'engueulade ben c'est un petit
peu ça aussi donc voilà je pense que les
Français ne lu tiennent pas rigueur et
croyez-moi si tous les hommes publics
avaient sa hauteur de vue et son respect
de la nation ça se passerait pas comme
ça aujourd'hui on parle de l'actualité
du Sénat le Sénat qui poursuit l'examen
du budget ce soir place à la partie dont
vous êtes rapporteur spécial les crédits
des médiat de l'audiovisuel un budget en
hausse on en parle tout de suite avec
audre
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour audre bonjour Audrey ce
soir les sénateurs se penchent donc sur
le budget de le di visuel public que le
gouvernement veut augmenter oui une
augmentation est pas des moindres plus 6
% en 2024 par rapport à 2023 quand on
prend l'ensemble he France Télévision
Radio France France méia monde é et Lina
l'Institut national de l'audiovisuel on
passe donc de 3illard 796 millions
d'euros de budget à un peu plus de 4
milliards mais sur cet ensemble il y a
une partie de l'argent qui est
conditionné il ne sera pererçu que si
des projets de transformation ou de
modernisation sont mis en place on pense
par exemple aux coopérations entre
France 3 et France Bleue en région au
développement d'une stratégie numérique
forte pour se rapprocher des jeunes ou
encore d'autres transformations en
interne rien et le Sénat n'est pas de
cet avis non parce qu'il y a des voyants
qui s'allument en rouge pour les
sénateurs d'abord quand on parle finance
depuis la suppression pour tous de la
redevance en 2022 il a fallu trouver une
autre manière de financer l'audiovisuel
public et pour cela on récupère une
partie de la TVA sauf que cette mesure
est temporaire elle doit prendre fin en
2025 mais aucune piste ne semble trouver
pour l'après vous avez donc Jeanron
Hugonet décidé de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme en bloquant l'augmentation de 6
% voulu par le gouvernement en fait on
gèle les crédits au niveau de 2023 en
clair c'est tant qu'on s'est pas mis
autour de la table pour trouver une
solution pour l'avenir on naugmente pas
le budget c'est aussi simple que ça
voilà non mais j'ai bien fait mon
travail je n'ai pas de note à mettre
mais c'est exactement ça si si je si je
peux un petit peu
développer nous c'est encore une fois ça
fait depuis 2015 le rapport le le GAT
Olympe ici au Sénat don nous sommes
c'est une devenu un peu une spécialité
l'audiovisuel publque et privé parce que
faut pas oublier qu'on marche quand même
sur deux jambes dans notre pays et bien
il y a longtemps qu'on dit qu'une
réforme est absolument nécessaire très
précisément la loi de 86 qui a été
rafistolée au moins 80 fois
depuis elle n'est plus voyez elle a un
corpus qui est encore fondé mais le
reste est l'univers numérique tout ça
est dépassé le gouvernement pour une
raison que j'ignore ou que je fin
alors que le Président de la République
habitué à ses sailis dans les médias
avait dit en novembre 2017 l'audiovisuel
publique est une honte pour nos
concitoyens moi je m'étais dit
benoitement ben il va nous montrer lui
qui sait qui est disruptif qui est jeune
et plein de dynamisme il va nous montrer
ce qu'il va faire or madame Nissen n'a
rien fait celui qui a voulu faire c'est
Franck rester il a suivi d'ailleurs
grandement dans sa loi dans son projet
dans son projet de loi je dis bien les
recommandations du Sénat on a détexter
le covid pour ne pas aller plus loin
alors que c'était passé en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale donc une réforme
est nécessaire et Roseline Bachelot est
arrivée pour faire l'atterrissage final
avec une petite loi qui était absolument
nécessaire sur le piratage et voilà
c'est tout ce qu'on a vu voilà et là on
voit bien que le pouvoir est pétrifié
dans l'audiovisuel public nous nous
avons des recommandations bah pétrifié
parce que forcément ça représente quand
même vous voyez ce que je veux dire une
certaine agitation quand vous avez
l'audiovisuel public qui est en grève ça
déplaî et forcément mais ça on peut le
comprendre mais il faut se dire une
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne pourra
plus avancer comme on l'a fait pendant
des années avec un avisard principal qui
n'est en décalage avec le marché voilà
ça c'est très clair quelle mission on
demande au Service Public quel périmètre
on lui affecte quel financement et
quelle gouvernance nous demandons ça on
ne voit rien donc il est hors de
question de voter des budgets maintenant
à l'aveugle dans l'état financier de
notre pays hein c'est un de ou voir pour
les parlementaires donc on refuse de le
faire on bloque les crédits on les gèle
ici au Sénat au niveau de ce qu'ils
étaient en 2023 et on nous demande là ce
qui est une honte absolue de nous de
nous proposer de nous par prononcer sur
une augmentation alors qu'on ne connaît
pas les contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens c'est surréaliste alors des
solutions pour l'avenir vous en avez
notamment pour faire des économies cet
été le Sénat a adopté en première
lecture une proposition de loi sur
l'audiovisuel public pour créer une
holding France média et faire fusionner
entre autres Radio France et France Télé
une proposition à laquelle la ministre
de la Culture avait répondu à l'époque
écoutez l'accélération depuis 3 ans de
la désinformation des
phénomènes de de d'égémonie des
plateformes je je pense que maintenant
l'urgence elle est plutôt d'approfondir
les coopérations telles qu'elles sont
lancées plutôt que de mettre toutes ses
énergies dans une nouvelle organisation
et dans un schéma de mécano
institutionnel qui va nécessairement
prendre énormément de temps on sait très
bien qu'en France Télévision est devenue
France Télévision le nombre d'années
qu'il a fallu pour créer une holding
puis une fusion c'est entre 9 et 12 ans
est-ce qu'on veut prendre ce temps pour
ce mécano institionnel ou est-ce qu'on
veut prendre ce temps pour avancer sur
les priorités sur lesquel nous sommes
d'accord qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
ah B que c'est la pure réponse techno
voilà c'est c'estàdire que le monde le
monde de l'entreprise le monde ça voilà
voyez on brandit on brandit le le mécano
mais pourquoi ça a pris tant de temps B
parce qu'il n'y a pas de volonté s'il y
a volonté c'est pas moi qui le disait il
y a un chemin mais je peux vous garantir
que enfin regardeer rassembler les
présidents de l'audiovisuel privé et les
les présidents de l'audiovisuel public
et organisons un débat on va voir ce qui
en sort je vous garantis qu'il y a des
vérités d'évidence que l'audiovisuel
public ne veut pas voir et on les
comprend encore une fois je sais c'est
pas une pierre dans le jardin de
Delphine Hernot ou cbil ve c'est pas
pour ne pas parler que d'elle des deux
principaux mais de France Radio France
mais mais parce que c'est pour est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une crainte de
suppression d'emploi peut-être mais les
craintes de suppression d'emploi encore
une fois c'est la même chose avec la
fonction publique territoriale je fais
un rapprochement vous voyez tant qu'on
va vivre sur ces brisées là ça ne pourra
pas fonctionner ça veut pas dire que
demain des gens so doivent se retrouver
à la rue il s'agit de la meilleure
utilisation possible des deniers des
Français et en terme d'audiovisuel ce
n'est pas le cas mais est-ce que pour ça
il faut supprimer certaines chaînes ah
bah quand je parlais de périmètre c'est
une évidence en plus dans l'audiovisuel
public les les chaînes se servent
justement de cette multiplicité de
chaînes pour faire passer sur des
chaînes annexes des obligations les
quelques obligations qu'ont le service
public alors que le côté du côté du
privé ils sont matraqués ils sont
complètement cadrés eux au jour jour
avec un parcours du combattant à peine
croyable alors que de l'autre côté
l'audiovisuel public à la bride sur le
coup ça ce n'est plus acceptable et
quelle chaîne il faut supprimer alors
pour vous c'est pas c'est pas à moi de
le dire là encore une fois mais c'est
une réflexion qui doit y avoir
communément on le sait on le voit bien
c'est même pas les supprimer pour les
supprimer il n'y a plus moyen de
financer de cette façon là la structure
de l'audiovisuel public tel qu'on la
connaît alors que l'on doit développer
le numérique le la ministre est entre
les deux eau elle sait très bien que sur
le numérique nous avons un retard
considérable qui a fait des choses dans
le numérique dans l'audiovisuel public
français Radio France et é
Arté qui est remarquable de ce point de
vue-là sinon qu'est-ce qu'on a à à
mettre en avant salto vous voulez qu'on
reparle de salto où 65 millions de de de
d'argent public ont été quasiment mis à
la poubelle dans un échec
notoire ça c'est pas c'est plus possible
voilà et et le conditionnement d'une
partie de ces de ces du financement du
budget à ces synergies c'est pas assez
c'est du bricolage mais c'est pas la
carotte et le bâton c'est vous l'avez
employé tout à l'heure ce qui manque à
l'audiovisuel public c'est français
c'est une stratégie il n'y a pas de
stratégie nous avançons dans le
brouillard et là je me mets à la place 2
minutes on les auditionne fréquemment je
les rencontre souvent Delphin an sibil
veille qui nous disent leur anxiété
elles doivent piloter rendez-vous compte
France Télévision Radio France avec
quand même pas mal de monde àord comme
vous l'avez dit sans savoir de quoi
demain est fait la LOLF au 1er janvier
2025 quand le président de la République
a sorti encore une fois une sortie
médiatique je supprime la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public français j'ai pas
vu d'ailleurs des Français manifester je
veux je veux retrouver la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public et me taper dessus
voyez j'en ai pas vu hein et bien quand
il a sorti ça le plan B n'était même pas
présenté on ne sait pas comment on va
aboutir on a c'estàd qu'aujourd'hui le
financement d'audiovisuel est en danger
pour vous alors en danger ceux qui
disent qu'en France ça y est on serait
dans un pays totalitaire où règne une
chap de plomb non ça je n'y crois pas 2
secondes vous voyez il faut pas faut
être mesuré en revanche et comme je l'ai
dit quand j'ai été reçu aux états
généraux de l'information on me pose
cette question l'audiovisuel public en
France n'est pas menacé pour la bonne et
simple raison et vous le savez peut-être
mais si le président de la République
avait besoin de s'exprimer à tous les
Français dans un cas d'extrême urgence
pour le pays ce que je ne souhaite pas
il pourrait le faire via le service
public parce que il y a tous les moyens
y compris technique pour le faire donc
ça c'est fondamental on a vu si j'élargi
un peu le spectre au moment du covid que
l'audiovisuel public était absolument
nécessaire parce que là encore il faut
s'adresser à la France entière donc sur
le fond il n'est pas en danger sur la
forme il est en grand danger puisque le
modèle sur lequel il est construit ne
tient plus ne tient plus financièrement
sauf si on pense que on gère la France
avec du quoi qu'il en coûte et un
déficit avec une dette à 3000 mais
quelle quelle solution alors est-ce que
il faut par exemple rétablir la
publicité après
20h alors ça ça va excusez-moi à
l'encontre de ce qu'on dit au Sénat pour
avoir un identifiant de qualité sur le
service public il faudrait en bannir la
publicité ben oui mais comment on fait
pour les finances est-ce que c'est pas
un pe est-ce que c'est pas incompatible
mais si vous voulez avancer avec le même
périmètre le périmètre il faut le
réduire donner une mission au service
public qui n'est plus de con et qui
n'est pas qui n'a jamais été de
concurrencer le privé comme ils le font
de façon quasi permanente voilà mais
permettre d'avoir une information
vérifiée solide voilà que les Français
savent trouver c'est c'est à mon sens on
en parle en 2 minutes c'est c'est la
direction une mission avec un cap mais
on lui donne une mission très claire et
le budget qui va avec merci Audrey à à
tout à l'heure on va parler d'autres
choses oui on va parler mesures venu de
la droite pour éviter les récidives des
auteurs d'actes de terrorisme sera ch
dans le club on va l'actualité dans
votre département pour terminer
jean-rmonoun on va r retrouve Ted V
rédacteur en chef du républicain de
l'esson bonjour Teddy merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous avec vous aussi on va
parler d'un tout autre sujet on va
parler droit de mutation et l'impact de
leur baisse sur les finances des
départements
oui bonjour Orian bonjour jeanonet
effectivement le département de lesson
fait face àén diminution de ses
ressources pour 2024 les les droits de
mutation à titre onreux MTO he comment
on les appelle c'est - 80 millions pour
pour l'année prochaine bon un peu de TV
en moins également moins une douzaine de
millions ajoutter à cela à cette
diminution des ressources des
compétences obligatoires sur lequel
département n'a pas la main je prends
l'exemple du RSA la compétence sociale
on peut s'interroger dans ces conditions
voilà avec d'une part cette baisse de
ressources d'autre part ces compétences
obligatoires un budget sur lequel
finalement il se murmure que les élus
n'auraient la main que sur 3,5 % du
budget pour faire les ajustements et
est-ce que l'existence des départements
a encore un sens que vraiment connaît
moin dans ce contexte et avec les moyens
qu'on lui
donne alors déjà bonjour Teddy et je je
voudrais saluer l'importance pour nous
d'une d'une presse comme celle du
républicain dans les sones et et dans
tous les dép appartement parce que là on
est dans la proximité les choses sont
très claires le pouvoir politique et ça
fait un moment que ça dure c'est pas
uniquement dirigé vers une couleur
politique dans notre pays a une tendance
ainsi que la technocratie de notre pays
à saper les deux piliers de base de
notre République que sont la commune et
le département ce sont des piliers qui
fonctionnent qui ont montré dans le
temps qu'ils ont une extrême résilience
pour reprendre un mot à la mode
aujourd'hui on est arrivé à une
situation le département n'a plus aucune
dynamique fiscale c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
il ne peut même plus décider de ses
recettes on est loin de l'article 72 sur
la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales voilà de la
constitution de 58 ça il ne peut plus le
faire et en même temps que le
département lui coupe ses dynamiques
fiscal on lui colle tous les jours tous
les jours des charges supplémentaires
pour l'étouffer c'est ce qui passe les
communes c'est la même chose il nous
reste encore la taxe foncière et encore
vous ne pouvez pas y toucher comme vous
voulez puisque Bercy vous encadre voilà
la taxe d'habitation a été supprimée
c'est un travail de SAP qui a commencé
il y a déjà bien longtemps et qui arrive
là dans l'entonnoir donc dès que un fait
de société
l'écroulement sur le marché de
l'immobilier nous le vivons dans les
communes parce que les droits de
mutation ce qu'on appelle les d not
frais de notaire pour que ce soit plus
simple à chaque fois qu'un transaction
se fait sur bien nous avons voilà que ça
soit le département ou les communes donc
nous subissons de plein fouet également
c'est 30 % du budget du département 80
millions d'euros c'est énorme voilà et
en même temps vous avez des charges qui
augmentent pour les communes c'est la
même chose je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que c'est une clairement une
technique on va pas supprimer les
communes les départements ça serait de
prendre trop de risque parce que les
Français les aiment et les identifient
mais on va tout simplement les étouffer
et ça je peux vous dire qu'ici au Sénat
on laissera pas faire ça et justement
tedy vous aviez aussi une une question
sur les communes même si je crois que
Jean un petit peu répondu ouais il y a
il y a répondu par anticipation
effectivement pour les communes une
réunion avec la préfecture en début de
semaine on a annoncé au qu'il fallait
prévoir sur sur les droit de mutation 25
% sur le budget est-ce que le budget
2024 ça pas être le budget de tous les
dangers pour nos communes petites ou
grande dans tout le département non
mais vous imaginez quand même où on en
est aussi où il faut que l'État nous
dise comme si on était à la la
maternelle attention les communes il
faut prévoir ça pour l'année prochaine
le président du Département mon ami
François durouvraet bien entendu a
communiqué toutes les communes de
lessones ont pris d'ailleurs vont
prendre ou ont pris déjà une
délibération au conseil municipal une
motion pour attirer l'attention vous
pensez bien quand le département subit
30 % automatiquement si vous êtes un
petit peu cérébré et ben vous prévoyez
pour votre commune un petit peu la même
chose et même pas 25 % je préviris je
prévois pour le budget de la commune
moin 30 % parce qu'on va y avoir droit
tout pareil et on le voit aujourd'hui
les ventes s'écroulent merci tdor merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous c'est le
Téléton à la républiain de les son la
force est puissante avec le Téléton le
Téléton qui aura lieu ce weekend hein on
on le rappelle merci Jeanron Hugonet
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
à très vite j'espère